if you had to fire someone from the Jets
who would it be oh my god if I had a
father if somebody from New York Jets it
would be oh this is really good
you got your prospective
[Applause]
[Music]
how are you Chris
Josh Josh how are you thank you guys 17
years old going off the NYU next year -
40 being fairly awesome it's about three
four years ago I started a business
called EJB entertainment so it's an
event and video production company I
love the business I love the leadership
and love the creativity so I think it's
the next step of how can I continue I
think that's a good observation so for
me that's kind of weirdly what I was
hoping you would say if you're asking
what's the next step for me I think you
actually view this next four years as a
context builder and education you know
you know excursion and so for me my hot
take is how do you get closest to you
know and you've heard this for me if you
follow me how do you get closest to who
you want to be get as close to the Sun
of the thing that you want to be and you
will win if you're capable like if you
want to be Jimmy Fallon if you want to
be Steven Spielberg at all costs you
need to work for those people for free
like to me the if I think back to what
did I do and there's always things to do
better I think that I didn't have to go
back to Springfield Jersey and work at
Wine Library all four years I think one
of those years working at Walmart
corporate office in Bentonville would
have done me a lot of good so I think if
you've made the commitment to like hey
I'm going to learn certain things from
NYU I would say with every other minute
you have instead of building a business
which you've already done and have some
understanding about I would try to get
more context from things that you want
to be right like I'm flabbergasted by
kids taking a job they hate for $4,000
more so they can buy something or have
slightly have two roommates instead of
three versus when they want to be
something having the access to that from
you know seventeen to twenty five to
then go on and do it for the rest of
their lives so for me making people
laugh and producing movies it's it's
[ __ ] what comedian can you work for
for free and get us
to me it's like if you have your four
favorite comedians and they all say yes
whoever lets you be the closest to real
life because the context of seeing it is
disproportionately valuable chase you
you watch me from afar you did what de
rock did for others what was the biggest
thing you learned in the first 30 days
of being here that wasn't obvious even
though you passionately watched us from
afar so to me what he learned in like
week one is like disproportionately
valuable like lack of like eliminating
subjectiveness and valuing speed and
output is a 20-19 model that matters
because the Internet's distribution is
unlimited
whereas old television and film you had
to overthink it because you put it out
once and that was that the it's volume
the best the best thing that can happen
to you is having an experience similar
to that within the craft that you care
about
[Music]
my name is Allie D and I met you long
ago I'm a radio personality on Sirius XM
radio I'm also a celebrity event planner
and right now I'm living on between my
dreams and my reality I have a 9 to 5
job and I recently you know have made
some money off of my career so my
question is when is the right time for
me to say I gotta leave this job
whenever you can afford to predicated on
how you live your lifestyle like I think
a lot more people out there can leave
their jobs a lot earlier if they're
willing to live less fancy and realize
that happiness is the ROI in life I mean
the amount of people who are watching
this right now who I would just wish
would sell their home go rent which
would then allow them to quit their job
or if they're renting stop buying dumb
[ __ ] which would allow them to leave
their job the real answer is when can I
go to my dream versus my reality it's
predicated on how much you're spending
in your real life on [ __ ] you don't need
now everyone's in different life cycles
when I look at these youngsters
especially if somebody's under 25 I'm
like live with 19 of your [ __ ]
friends and eat [ __ ] 99-cent [ __ ]
White Castle and go
your stomach's still good like you can
go right other people have kids and
they're like but to me the conversation
that nobody's having is what your
expenses look like we're space to do
respect but like the question is but you
could live you could and not that I
think you should the question no for a
lot of people is like ham especially
people that have a little something
going you know people that are still in
their head and haven't even started
singing or selling rom or doing events
like that they probably have to wait a
little bit for some foundation but like
to me it's like when do you jump in the
pool like right when you're a kid like
it just happens right you could but then
you would say to me but if we were
having drinks oh we were best friends
since grammar school you be like yeah
but I
to do that like I'm dating or this is
like there's a like there is no right
answer but the reason I'm giving you
this answer is nobody's talking about
expenses like I've had this conversation
with some friends and after an hour over
like a hot dog
you realize like maybe you don't have to
do your nails three times a week maybe
you don't have to go to two vacations
you can go to what like it gets really
interesting I think it comes down to how
much is your reality killing you and how
much is your dream pulling at you right
some people the deltas enormous they
[ __ ] hate their job and they just
love singing more than breathing so for
me I'm like go rogue for other people
like go oh my my I don't love my job
that's I you know like I think like
three out of five days a week I'm like
cool I like my cohort like and my dream
is like I really really like it
that becomes the question right the
reason I was a DNF student was I
couldn't breathe if I wasn't an
entrepreneur long before it was
something cool and that's who I became
the same way that athletes just they
suck at school they suck at everything
else like the ones that make it to the
league they stay out of trouble they
suck at school they make it to the
league cuz they were just they couldn't
breathe if they weren't playing ball do
you understand and that's the Delta
that's the actual practical answer to
your question what's going on a levy
with Jerry be for the quickest interview
I've ever done
what is the shittiest wine you've ever
tasted bérenger White Zinfandel ok um if
you had to fire someone from the Jets
who would it be
oh my god if I had a party somebody from
New York Jets it would be oh this is
really good the parking attendants okay
um what Kardashian sister has the best
branding uh Kendall Kendall oh that's
interesting okay I'm a marathon runner
and I think Kendall is playing the
longest game of the bunch
okay and my last question rapper Soulja
Boy said he had the best comeback of
2018 better than tiger in your opinion
who had the best comeback that's 180
Kodak
really mm-hmm can you see why quickly
because this album is just next-level
you